Hello, I started a business that takes the men out of mentoring.
It's called raise the Crowd Studio because it takes a village, right?
Some really exciting news about my second business,
raise the crowd. I'm also the co and founder of she's a crowd,
which is a data driven global tech startup
which closes the gender data gap to address sexual violence.
But I also started raise the crowd with a couple of other women
to support female and non binary founders
to thrive and grow their businesses
organically and sustainably
and achieve their dreams. Now when I was younger,
I've been in the social impact space,
entrepreneur space for 14 years.
And when I was younger, I got paired a lot with mentors
and they were pretty much always men back in those days
and they would spend all their time telling me
how much they respect women
or talking down to me
and I even got sexually harassed by one of the mentors
I was paired with. So we help diverse people solve diverse problems.
We don't want more Mark Zuckerberg clones.
We wanna see a world where these problems are taken seriously
and invested in.
I have noticed so many gaps over the years in what is provided
specifically to diversity founders.
So we have a social worker on board who helps with neurodiversity
and things like accountability,
mentoring and um, organizational challenges.
We do brand development, business development, marketing,
grant writing and attracting funding
and Every single client gets a personalised development plan
and then a social worker checking in with them every single week.
We wanna hone in on specifically what women
and diversity founders need
and provide that to them so that they can thrive and grow,
achieve their dreams. We're nominated
and we're on the leaderboard for the Spark Business Grants.
So that means we just need a couple hundred more votes
and then we'll get $10,000 so that we can help you
for $10,000. That's gonna allow us to grow our business and support
and continue to provide
discounts and free advice to as many different
diversity founders as we can.
I personally could not have started she's a crowd
or raise the crowd without help from incredible women
and that's what we're trying to do for others.
So if any of this resonates with you,
please vote for us. We need your votes.
We need your support.
My team have asked me to come on here and ask you for your votes.
Um, you can also get in touch with us if any of this resonates
and if you are starting a side hustle,
have an idea or have already got a business,
but you just need that extra support,
um, we'd love to hear from you.
So I'll put all the links below. Thank you.